you can call off your search for  talkable stories but I do Kate found  them all and what a service and I'm  right here that's it take it away my  friend good to see you all here a few  stories we think you'll be talking about  today for Mississippi State prisons are  the focus of a federal civil rights  investigation after a series of inmate  deaths CBS News has been on top of this  story since it broke at least 15 people  have died in sight state facilities  since late December and as recently as  last weekend the probe will explore  whether prison officials have done  enough to adequately protect inmates  from physical harm the quality of mental  health care and suicide prevention  efforts are also under investigation  last month rappers jay-z and Yo Gotti  helped more than two dozen Mississippi  inmates file a lawsuit problem they said  it was culmination of years of severe  understander staffing and neglect we're  gonna stay on